supongamos que ya es igual a logaritmo
base 4dx al cuadrado más x entonces cuál
es la derivada de y con respecto a x
bueno tal vez te des cuenta
inmediatamente que ésta es una función
compuesta porque estamos tomando el
logaritmo base 4 pero no de x sino de
una expresión que involucra a x de hecho
podríamos decir que esta expresión es
otra función llamada de x x es igual a x
al cuadrado más x y bueno seguro va a
ser útil más adelante tener a la mano la
derivada de a que es utilizando la regla
de las potencias nos queda que es 2x + 1
aquí tomé el exponente y lo puse al
principio y luego le reste 1 y la
derivada de x con respecto a x es 1
esta función logaritmo base 4 también
podemos decir que es una función de de x
entonces esta función de de x es el
logaritmo base 4 de x y queremos tener a
la mano su derivada ahora esta derivada
ya la hemos visto en otros vídeos es muy
parecida a la derivada del logaritmo
natural pero como estamos tomando el
logaritmo base 4 lo único que tenemos
que hacer es escalar la la derivada del
logaritmo base 4 de x es uno entre el
logaritmo natural de 4 por x si
tuviéramos por acá simplemente el
logaritmo natural de x la derivada sería
1 / x este término de aquí logaritmo
natural de 4 viene del cambio de base
del logaritmo base 4 a logaritmo natural
y las fórmulas de cambio de base y todas
estas cosas las puedes repasar en uno de
nuestros vídeos pero finalmente lo único
que hace este término que es constante
escalar a esta función hacerla más
pequeña pero bueno ahora sí ya tenemos
todo lo que vamos a utilizar aquí ya se
puede escribir como ve de porque ve es
la función logaritmo base 4dx y estamos
evaluando a b en esta expresión pero
esta expresión es la función y entonces
tenemos b dv de x bueno pero voy a poner
por aquí unas líneas para separar estos
dos lados y como sabemos que ésta es una
función compuesta sabemos por la regla
de la cadena que la derivada de ye con
respecto a x es la derivada de esta
función con respecto a un o sea de
primer evaluada en de x
de x
por la derivada de v con respecto a x
osea q prima de x y entonces vamos a
hacer esto por acá tenemos b prima de x
y a partir de eso podemos construir b
prima de v x lo único que tenemos que
hacer es cada que veamos una x
sustituirla por una u de x así es que
esto es igual a b prima en nube x o sea
la derivada de la función logaritmo base
4 evaluada en la función azul por acá
tenemos la derivada y la queremos
evaluar en esta expresión azul entonces
nos queda uno entre logaritmo natural de
4 por x pero en lugar de poner a x vamos
a poner un x
y de equis y luego esto lo estamos
multiplicando por prima de x por prima
de x y estoy haciendo muchos pasos para
que quede muy claro pero esto es igual a
1 / logaritmo natural de 4 por ud x pero
ud x es x al cuadrado más x y luego
multiplicamos por su prima de x que es 2
x + 1 y esto es igual a 2 x + 1 /
logaritmo natural de 4
por x al cuadrado más equis y listo ya
terminamos podríamos distribuir el
logaritmo natural de 4 en esta expresión
pero sólo si nos interesará no es
necesario aquí ya tenemos la derivada de
jake con respecto a x